hello and welcome to this video playing
is at 79 forgotten was that is an TP how
yo solo yeah Andres taking places this
line okay oh my god I've totally forgot
this is not particularly great but I
have forgotten why and think this one
yeah it's one of those trick lines where
you have you know if you know it black
it's just better if you don't know it
you can be worse Jack thinks this is
correct
Reggie for chick I think it's right jack
okay hmm yes I know the question is
what's happening here with this night
down go ahead do i do this got this
check though yeah okay I cannot cannot
spend our time here Queen d6 looks very
logical okay and then then he goes what
what the beep I Nikki does what he goes
to h2 probably if I go if I go back it's
going tween know it's going King h2 i
also have c5
okay i'm going back and we have time
wise this has already been a huge
success for him no matter how good or
bad is this i mean check i'm down on
time a lot
yeah it's always always something that
you can do and let's play some line that
is essentially incorrect but hope that
the other guy doesn't know the
reputation which happens here I didn't
remember it really is a bad line but
this is probably not the reputation
okay I have to go back to da I guess one
i mean i can actually castle this is not
I can't cancel in this position okay if
I go back now it's tough to I think i
forgot 95 at some point this is the
thing anyway anyway let's play
okay now i cannot cancel if i go bishop
is six days but probably ninety five
yeah it looks very slow it doesn't
prepare really but should be six I mean
we should be six I can play with after
catalyst is called f5 so this is a bad
idea probably
yeah this is taking some time
now that makes some sense opening up
opening things up
I'm thinking about a six route 87 here
at least he's catching up a little bit
on the clock that's good i think as some
95 that i forgot
Jack oh I didn't see that one goodnights
97 now Jack I what a shame and Jack what
did damn shame maybe I can at least get
a pawn for it I mean maybe I can get it
back and then just pawn down maybe if he
has to check on b6 it's not that bad I
mean I'm not happy but what a bad game
no
now those trick lines are always a
little bit of a problem blitz and in
tournament chess you can classical time
control you can find find this stuff
over the board but in blitz it's a bit
tricky
gives you're wondering I'm not living
directly close to a church but this
church it has enormously loud Bell said
that it's really loud in fact it it's
not right next to me 9500 it's just
check
time warning check check
let's go Bishop age 41 okay
and always got some stuff hanging here
check check check
check okay position is ok now I think
check jets very okay check five seconds
this is a check most difficult part of
it check check brah ha ha ha ha ok go
jab I really am I need to check the
opening um yeah this is really no good
but what's could remember it I hey this
is this is correct jack i'm pretty sure
about it and that's some 95 in some
position but i don't i don't remember it
jack maybe i'm confusing things possible
queen 27 of course i have to go back to
d7 that's probably a lot bad I here
because this is helping in playing
Bishop e7 and castles I mean you know
how can this be good yeah what has given
up the bishop pair is worse in the
center the king is funny here I just
have to get cash lot and now I do with
Bishop e7 and castles sure okay this is
the thing this is getting getting really
tricky now yeah I can castle I saw that
but at I couldn't I didn't really trust
it you know this kind of thing I didn't
trust it I thought this pawn would be
too weak I thought he goes back and then
the spawn is weak but then my
development is pretty good engine gives
equal
and now I'm in trouble problem yeah Jack
Jack Jack down this poem it's not such a
big deal actually maybe he had something
better the engine wants to take and just
develop this is maybe better I'm
threatening Bishop a five yeah things
have gone Jack White wrong and Jack Jack
I mean this might be still kind of okay
because of the opposite colored bishops
I have some activity him but I really
got into trouble here I think Jack ok
and here i actually have kinky five yeah
I didn't dare to play that the engine is
yeah this is of course I can go here
right yes this I didn't see here black
is clearly better already it's losing
stuff I didn't see that no and it seemed
far too shaky to me but now he's better
of course then all of a sudden we have
this situation Jack Jack Jack again it's
it's jack this ending is ok for me jack
I will always have come to play against
those pawns Oh tough game yeah a tough
game tricky opening line that that I'm I
didn't play properly I should go to the
seven instead of b6 okay well thanks for
watching